malaria is a complex organism it's a  eukaryotic pathogen it has over 5000  genes it exists  in the insect vector and in the human  host it exists in the liver  and in the red cell malaria eradication  means eliminating an organism from the  face of the earth  and to do that we need to understand the  biology of the organism in order to  develop the necessary tools drugs  vaccines and other interventions in  addition the parasites ability to adapt  to external challenges to drugs to the  human immune system to the mosquito  vector  make it a fascinating biological system  parasites have evolved with us for  millennia they know how to hide out they  know how to live with us  the course brings together people from  malaria control programs from  non-governmental organizations from  academic institutions to work together  to develop the skills that are needed to  lead this effort